this is luke with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and this is my son
tommy and nathan and i'm here in the
heart of alaska with my friend jake from
the how to alaska youtube channel and
his sons
cody and luke and we're about to go on
an incredible
snow machining winter camping adventure
where almost
everything goes wrong i think you guys
are going to enjoy this adventure
you ready nate we're gonna have a good
old time
all right we've had some trouble with
the trailer popping off the hitch
so we've used some alaskan ingenuity
here
we got pretty pink zip ties and a piece
of willow
i think that'll actually work
[Applause]
we're trying to cross this big river
here but you don't necessarily want to
be the first one across so we're looking
for some snow machine tracks where
someone safely crossed
jake's all the way down the river here
and he's trying to look for a place to
safely cross
you can see here we go this is where
overflow happens where water pops up and
flows over the top of the ice
and then it's frozen again but there's a
lot of weird spots on the ice because
the river will freeze and then the water
levels will drop and there'll be these
big air pockets
in between the ice and the gravel bar
the water and you can bust through into
these little
airpods it's crazy so we're gonna we're
gonna see if we can find a good spot
all right well it looks like we can't
find any really good places to cross the
river so we're gonna pivot
and uh we're gonna try another spot here
luckily it's alaska
so there's plenty of awesome places to
go
[Music]
all right well originally we're gonna go
and try to ice fish for some big trout
but uh since we couldn't cross the river
instead we're gonna try to go up here
and
maybe catch a snowshoe hare or a grouse
or a tarmigan
but we need to drop the trailer off and
get our camp set up
[Applause]
yes
got the tent up now i gotta get the
stove assembled
slide the rings over this thing only one
all right we got the ted set up we got
some firewood we're gonna drop the
trailer and take the snow machines up
into the pass
see if we can't find some rabbits or
tarmac and uh
hopefully we'll have a little something
to cook up for dinner
all right tom you ready
foreign right now we're looking for
tarmigan
and this time of year they turned white
so we're looking for an all-white
bird in the middle of all this snow
oh there's one two three four moose up
there
i think we've seen like 11 or 12 moose
on this trip
jake spotted some fresh tarmac and
tracks right there heading down into
that goalie
maybe we'll go follow that nathan what
did you guys do
i think you hit a tree
two more moose over that way they're
just everywhere up here
[Music]
well it's been a little eventful getting
back to camp
luke got a snow machine stuck in a
goalie and it took a good 30 40 minutes
for all of us to get it out
and by the time we got it out jake's
snow machine had cooled down
and the clutch froze so it's not
starting
yeah we're good hour or so into just
messing with snow machines
here watch out you don't want this strap
snapping back at you either
there we go all right we towed the snow
machine all the way back to camp
and uh we're gonna get a fire started
get some food and get this tent warmed
up
it's cold out there's our bag of
vaseline and
cotton balls here
you might want to back up this stuff
yeah that's burning good all right nate
you want some chocolate milk
whoa we got chocolate milkshake okay
oh yeah okay chocolate milkshake right
there
all right should we get some dinner
going yeah i like it
all right guys we're gonna have the most
amazing tinfoil dinners ever
they've got a little olive oil and
seasoned potatoes carrots
onions green onions a little cilantro
basil and italian sausage with
just a little bit of garlic oh yeah
you can put anything you want in tin
foil dinner just make sure the stuff
that
cooks the longest goes on the bottom and
then make sure
you remember which side is up every
kicked butt which always
hell
[Applause]
oh that smells good guys i think this is
perfect who wants a tinfoil dinner here
the key is that italian sausage man it's
so seasoned
so well you want one yeah
our water froze solid so we're sticking
it here by the fire trying to thaw it
out
hey guys did you like the tinfoil
dinners yeah would you like to try some
cow piss
it's a soft drink from japan it's not
carbonated but it's made
from fermented milk yep it's called
calpis
or in english they call it calpico cody
then give it to me
we'll make that that's really good
bottoms up
hard try some cow piss whoa
uncut it's almost like it's got citrus
in it
nathan you want hot chocolate oh nathan
you're melting your boot again
pull your boot in that warm you up buddy
yeah oh good well we had a lovely dinner
a lovely set by a warm fire
but uh jake and his boys are gonna head
home and take care of that broke down
snow machine
and uh me tom and nate are gonna sit
here and camp all night
tomorrow we've got some fun planned i
think we're gonna try to go
and see if we can't do a little hunting
and maybe do a catch and cook we'll see
what happens
all right see you guys
you got a long way to tow that
snowmobile
here come on i got your beds all made up
guys
why don't you go take off your jackets
[Music]
now can i leave you guys for a little
bit i need to go clean up out
well i popped outside for a few minutes
to get the cap all ready for night and i
come back in and both boys are
out stone cold man well the weather is a
whole lot warmer than the last time we
used this tent
it's five degrees fahrenheit outside and
so it is
really toasty in here and you can see
there really isn't
hardly any frost on the tent just a
little bit down here but it's
more like condensation really so i think
we're gonna be
really warm tonight and uh i'm glad i'm
getting old man
i need to be toasty warm at night
oh yeah that's toasty i've got no cell
service out here so i'm using my garmin
inreach mini to text becca and let her
know we're safe and
everything's okay before we go to bed so
busy fidgeting with everything i never
got a chance to eat a
full tin foil dinner so i shoved this
one underneath the stove and it's warmed
it up
i don't think i'm gonna have some dinner
there's a few things i love as much as a
good mandarin orange but uh
these are a bit hard i better thaw them
out i'm gonna lay my oranges here by the
fire
and i'm gonna hop into bed maybe watch a
show on my phone and i'm gonna go to
sleep and i'm gonna see you guys
in the morning it's about eight in the
morning right now
and we've got the fire going really good
nathan still asleep so me and tommy
are gonna watch shows on my phone a
little bit you wanna watch star wars
yes
all right nathan you sleep well yeah but
anyway we're liking star wars
no man
that's a walk
let's defrost some sausages here well
jake and his family were kind enough to
let us have some of the fresh eggs their
hens laid
we're gonna make hard-boiled eggs here
all right
there you go
yeah hey boys i think i hear snow
machines
oh i think we've got guests
good morning good morning here guys
let's get
let's get dressed that sounds like
yeah yeah
we have a pretty fun agenda planned for
today we're going to take snow machines
up into that valley
a little further than we went yesterday
and we're going to go look for tarmagan
and hopefully we'll catch them and we'll
be able to cook them up for lunch
um and so i'm going to go ahead and kind
of get everything packed up a little bit
so that we don't have to fuss as much
after we get back from hunting
but uh yeah i'm looking forward to this
[Applause]
we're mostly packed up you guys warmed
up let's get ready to go hunting
but we're gonna get hungry so i'm
bringing some hot dogs
there we go
are you having fun nathan yeah good
there's two moose right over there by
the trail we gotta be real careful
don't get kicked to death by a moose
there's one moose right there
there's another one over there and
there's one thing that the ground right
is
up there there's a moose there's the
moose there's two moose over there
and there's one over there the moves
look tiny from here but their heads are
about seven foot tall
jake went down the goalie where we got
stuck last night to go find a helmet
check out those three moves are right
there behind him
the reason why there's so many moves up
here is because the snow is shallower up
here near the top of the mountain
because the wind blows it away
also these little shrubs around here
these are willows and the moose eat the
bark off the
he willows his ears back he's cha and
chased the other one away
when they pull their ears back that
means they're angry i think he's gonna
walk away from us
try to avoid the moose
yeah moose scared me more than bears do
i don't like the boost
jake must have saw something he's got
the gun out oh i think he's aiming at
something
oh there you go
one down man that's beautiful they're so
pretty i'd love to get you on some birds
but i figured since i was that far away
just do it just get one
just get it might even get a snowshoe
hair you can see there's some hair
trails right there
so we were taking the snow machine up a
hill and hit the kill switch and the
machine died of course and
we couldn't get him turned back on
something's wrong with the machine
all right guys we've been monkeying with
this machine it looks like it's properly
stranded here
and that's why you come with friends you
don't go snow machining in the back
country of alaska by yourself
machines broke down it's a little bit of
an emergency situation what's the first
thing we do
build a fire drink our own urine can you
tow that machine out or are you with
that one or you have to get some friends
to help you
i can't tow it out with this one though
all right guys make sure to go to jake's
channel how to alaska and click
subscribe
because after he gets done with all
these engine repairs he's gonna need
your support
so make sure you do that please we're
gonna squeeze onto two machines and see
if we can get back to camp
we've uh sent out a help message with
our
garmin inreach so hopefully some friends
with the machine that can tow that one
out we'll
be coming along
we're heading back to camp and look what
i found
yeah big glob of moose hair i wonder if
they're biting each other but moose are
like reindeer they have these big hollow
hairs
all right we're halfway back to camp
we're just taking it slow and steady
this machine was not meant
to carry 250 pounds of me plus another
100 pounds of them
we're gonna test the brakes good
can we see if the hot dogs are done
all right are they cold or hot
lukewarm giving them another 5-10 miles
they would have been perfect
we got to thaw our buns out we froze our
buns off
all right who wants one
what we got ketchup shave eyes here i
was saying the other day
i've never
our heroes we're saved we don't have to
cannibalize the children
aren't they so so it wasn't like he was
rallying the machine or anything
should we go clean that target where
they're gonna go up and tow the snow
machine all the way back in the meantime
we're gonna go and clean that tarmagen
up oh man aren't these parmigian pretty
they're a brownish color in the summer
and then they turn white in the
wintertime but they're the alaska state
bird right here
and uh jake knows a lot more about
cleaning these than i do but i'm gonna
give it my best go since he's busy
rescuing a snow machine
look at the color of that meat see how
it's dark purple like that
because there's very little fat in it
wild meat is extremely lean
right so there's a bit of meat
a bit of meat there's the legs now i
know a lot of people like to eat the
gizzards and hearts and stuff but my
family
not so much so we're just gonna take
this home well i was gonna show you guys
how to cook a tarman over an open fire
but
i uh apparently left all my salt and
pepper at home
and uh because of all the craziness
today i think we're just gonna
continue that part of the video at the
house oh
we're working on this thing and see if
we can't get it to get it running again
well let me pull that other plug
that's the way it should but what was it
vapor why don't you
do jesse
that sounded promising
i think we might be getting out of here
hey nate you having fun yeah
you ready to go home yeah
[Music]
we made it back alive tommy are you okay
you tired
all right guys well we made it back in
one piece but now we got some tarmigan
to cook
there nathan your seat's over here bud
it is late and i am going to bed and i
will see you guys
in the morning
[Music]
i forgot the tarp again oh
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
luke nate and tom here with the outdoor
boys and today we're going to be hot
tenting it in the back country of alaska
this is going to be great
[Music]